A lot better than a lot of people
thought I was going to start with that.
It is a
rather surprising to me in some ways
that it's done this well this long
because I was taught at the University
of Chicago and northwestern that it was
terribly important for countries to have
savings and to invest a lot in the
future and that had a lot to do with how
well they're doing.
Well.
America today
has the lowest savings rate it has had
in many,
many years.
At the national level.
It's fallen dramatically from all 10,
11 percent of the GDP is,
we call it down to one or two personal
savings rates.
Stunningly,
I've gone from nine percent of our
disposable income to a minus one percent
and we become very gifted,
a ardent robust to consumers and
borrowers and savers.
Now the big question is we become huge
borrowers as a country with our very
large deficits.
We become borrowers at the consumer
level with very hard debt levels and a
really lousy savings levels.
And the big question I have about the
American economy is not today,
but it's how long we think we can
continue because we've got some huge
challenges that are coming.
We have 78 million baby boomers twice
the size of the current generation due
to begin retiring next year.
We have social security and Medicare
that are programs that are where we made
a lot of promises,
but we haven't funded them
and we've grossly misled.
The American people was such a
euphemisms as the social security trust
fund.
I argue it's oxymoron.
It shouldn't be trusted and it's not
funded because the money's already been
spent and we haven't provided for those
programs.
We are getting to be fancy language.
We have something called a current
account deficit which measures are
deaths.
It's abroad,
which is largely the trade depths.
It's now twice as high as a percentage
of the economy as it's ever been in
America's history and we're borrowing
and borrowing and becoming
dysfunctionally and I think
destructively,
but depending on the long run on Chinese
money,
in Japanese money in Asian money and so
forth and which they lend us money.
Funny thing about borrowing,
you have to pay it back at some time and
as a country we can't continue to borrow
a seven percent of the whole economy,
which is what we're borrowing now for
very many years without looking like a
very different America than we have now.
So I think the economy today is in
pretty good shape though,
was getting pretty turbulent now with
housing and housing is a wonderful
example.
I did quite a study about 18 months ago
and that was simply astonished at the
number of people who bought homes,
no money down.
It's called interest on me
and then I was astonished that even
though mortgage rates at the lowest
level in 30 years,
they've averaged around nine point seven
percent or something like that and now
they're like six people are not taking
longterm fixed mortgages.
About half of them are taking what are
called adjustable rate mortgages.
Well one might say,
gee,
that's fine.
If we have a lot of savings that we've
stacked away and if we aren't borrowing
very much for other purposes,
that isn't true.
We're borrowing more Maura's upset of
her income than we have in many,
many years.
So now we've had this big blow out of
the so called subprime mortgage market
and today I hear on the press that
housing prices are falling and so forth.
What did we think was gonna happen?
How are these loans going to get paid
back if we don't have any savings are
already heavily borrowed.
So my concerns about the economy of this
country are much more in the future and
much more of our culture.
We had become from one of the biggest
savers and the world and saving remember
as a metaphor for the future,
uh,
we've become the biggest consumers and
borrowers in the world,
which is kind of another way of saying,
Dang,
I want it all.
I want it now and I don't want to give
up anything and kind of to hell with the
future.
So I am a far more concerned with
America's economic future 10,
15,
20 years from now than I am.
What happens over the next months.
I am planning to
my,
a from blackstone going public.
A lot of it and it's quite a windfall
and set up a
what will turn out to be a very large
foundation
and because I've been boring people
relentlessly for the last 20,
30 years about some of these problems,
um,
I'm going to take a number of these
problems that are what I call
undeniable,
an unsustainable and yet politically
untouchable because of the political
culture we now live in where it's
considered almost politically terminal
ever asked anybody to give up anything
or pay for anything and you know,
I want more and more and more and I,
I want it now.
And to take these issues which I think
are serious threat to America's future
and uh,
take those issues where there's a huge
gap
between what we should be doing and what
we could be doing and what we are not
doing.
And figure out how at the margin
a major foundation might be able to make
a difference.
When I think of young people today and I
think of what we're leaving them
a 10,
15,
20 years from now,
you remind me of that old,
a joke in the philosophy class where the
professor asks the students,
which is worse,
ignorance,
ignorance or apathy,
and some poor kid from the back of the
class says,
I don't know,
and I don't care.
Well,
I think it's an interesting question.
Is there an exciting way that we could
get the young people to this country
aware and their parents because I
refused to believe that parents have
suddenly become cold and indifferent to
their own kids and grand computers.
I think they've been deceived and a
misinformed and disinfect and so forth,
so we have a political system today,
for example,
where the elderly are unbelievably well
represented.
The American Association of Retired
Persons as 38 dues paying $38 million
dues paying members.
They write more,
they lobby more,
they call more and by and large it's not
too unfair to say a lot of their
programs are.
We want more,
even though by any standard,
as I say,
some of these challenges are
unsustainable.
We can't,
we're not going to be able to meet the
promises that we've made.
So on the one hand we have these,
this culture of our ethic of shared
sacrifice being kind of a dirty word,
not wanting to give up anything.
We have political organizations who are
dominant in representing one age group
and the young people who were all about
the future or somehow being slipped this
huge check
hidden check I might add for our free
lunch and nobody seems to be doing
anything about it.
So I would like to gather together the
student and the young leaders of this
country and uh,
take a day or two and say,
try to give you the biggest best running
around I can and half a dozen areas of
the economy and fiscally and what the
world looks like.
And then I want you to contemplate that
because it's not my future.
It's yours.
I'm 81 years old.
I Lord knows I don't need anything more.
And ask you what are the best ways to do
something about it and should we have an
American Association of young people and
their parents,
for example,
because until this democracy gets
educated and get some form,
which is the first requirement,
and then get active and motivated.
Not much is going to happen on these
problems unless there's a huge crisis
and it will be a very costly crisis when
it hits.
So
that's a long winded answer how I feel
about the economy.
I I'm much more concerned about the
longterm picture that I am over the next
year or two or three.
My parents' generation,
the greatest generation for
fought the most costly war in history.
Costly in every sense of that word.
They built international institutions,
Marshall Plan and so forth,
which was central to the world getting
restored.
They had gi bill or rights for all the
returning veterans went to college.
They rebuild the infrastructure of this
country,
but they didn't ask me to pay for it.
They paid for it because they were
willing to invest in the future and that
meant saving.
And that meant consuming less.
I tell these university audiences,
I think a careful study of your
sociologist,
of your social psychologists,
have your political scientists of your
economists have your historians and say,
what was it during those early times and
where more Americans than I'm afraid
today had a clear sense of the future
and a responsibility for it and what led
us to this notion,
I'm going to grab what I can and the
government owes me this and the
government owes me that and a kind of to
hell with other people or to hell with
the future to hell with
who and how we're going to pay for all
this.
Now,
why did that come about?
What led to this boomer mentality?
You know,
about?
I wanted it all.
I got to enjoy it.
And uh,
I have a dear friend who
is there an aspect of the medical
profession.
He's kind of complaining that it's not
a,
Hey,
I'm
millionaire or mold omitted in her or
whatever.
And I said,
well,
you know,
one way people become millionaires is
they save and they invest,
but he's got to have a smaller plane and
he flies on the weekend.
Is he points out to me is not a jet,
and I said,
well,
I understand I don't have a jet either,
but,
and Oh,
um,
you know,
I need to have fun because I worked so
hard all week and I need a porsche car,
you know,
so forth.
And that is the boomer mentality that
we're kind of dealing with here and I
don't really know what lead from saving
and investing into the future,
which consoling and borrowing.
Now,
uh,
did America get a disenchanted by the
Vietnam war?
The tore this country apart?
Did we get torn apart by the
fascination of presidents and
presidents,
brothers and Martin Luther King and
riots in the streets?
And uh,
uh,
I was gonna say I was working on this
problem in Chicago is a terrifying side
to say.
And then somehow the bonds that united
us in Helios lead to the current
situation.
I'm not sure,
but I've never seen a time when there is
so much bitterness and partisanship and
paralysis as we have today in our
government.
I mean,
nothing went through areas or areas
where
the Republican leadership in the
democratic leadership are united for a
much longer larger cause,
namely the nation's interest.
We've had very little of that recently.
So I'm putting.
I don't know what all the reasons are.
I just know there's been a,
a really major shift.
I think if I may,
just to insult your medium,
it entirely possible that
television
has had its impact.
For example,
I used to watch my children,
I admire there wasn't television
and they turn on the TV
and pounded into their heads.
Here's this toy.
They had a habit,
there's the stress.
They gotta have this and we've developed
a kind of a
indulgent instinct,
gratification consumption,
large s,
uh,
that has become part of our culture.
And I don't,
I,
I don't know all the reasons for it,
but certainly the presence of such an
effective medium and television is
probably one of the,
uh.